bien égoutter c'est encore une fois moi
je ne ne crois pas au paradis un au
paradis communiste ou saas pour moi
c'est de la blague
ce qui ce qui importe comme le rappelle
frédéric c2c de gérer la violence
sociale
bien sûr que un rapport de un à trois
qui est quand même déjà vraiment très
gros c'est une énorme différence avec
les rapports que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui alors ça s'inspire des
rapport interdécile 1 le rapport
interdécile dans la fonction publique ou
dans les conventions collectives et
mieux négocier c'est à dire le rapport
entre la moyenne des 10 % les plus
faibles salaires est la moyenne des 10 %
des plus forts salaires il est en gros 2
à 3 mais entre les salaires elle il peut
être effectivement danilo 10000
sachant qu'en ensuite via les impôts qui
en france quand même réduisent l'écart
mis un petit oui bien sûr alors
maintenant sur
le fait qu'il y ait à une hiérarchie des
qualifications
si pour moi il ya deux raisons l'une qui
empirique 1 a pas d'humour nous sommes
tous titulaires d'un salaire comme
droits politiques
il n'est pas sûr que notre notre désir
de trajectoires professionnelles
rejoignent les besoins sociaux il faut
bien un ajustement qui peut se faire par
une hiérarchie des salaires qui fait que
quelqu'un qui travaillera deux nuits
dans industries de process ou à
l'hôpital avec une action d'une activité
qui nuit quand même à sa santé montre ap
le vide en qualifications par exemple et
puis la deuxième raison qui elle est
profonde c'est qu'il ya du tragique dans
la société et que
gérer les pouvoirs de violents les
violences les pouvoirs qu'il y a dans
toute activité de production
[Musique]
l'argent est une bonne façon de
d'objectiver les rapports sociaux et
donc
gérer ces rapports par une hiérarchie
des salaires ça a du sens alors c'est
pas je ne sais pas c'est pas le paradis
mais encore une fois elle frédéric et
moi on est absolument d'accord là-dessus
tout anthropologie enchanté sur le
communisme nous mène au désastre
[Musique]